tout est en place on à la scénographie
qui a été très étudiée par les deux
candidats sur le champ de mars my mac il
me fait ça dort c'est la puce et là je
pense la campagne a été longue je
n'ai pas venu d'aérobic non il n'est pas
la nuit c'est un franchement c'est un
grand regret c'est un gros regret pour
moi et honnêtement je pense que in fine
je pense que rmc en l'occurrence rmc et
bfm tv le matin à 8h30 c'est un rendez
vous très franc c'est un c'est un vrai
moment d'échangé mais je suis pas une
groupie mais voilà je sais pas pourquoi
cette émission m'a donné beaucoup dans
la vie de la basse et je m'étonne 268
l'euro hormis la faisant ils m'aident
moi parlons bien parlons un peu ça nous
intéresse pas les rapports humains vous
intéresse pas on voit ce que cet autre
rapport qui vous intéressent vous
et chambre à gilles bouleau qui est
vraiment être un super partage c'est
vrai je vous le dis c'est arrivé il est
fair play il est sympa il est libéré
alors oui je le reverrai s'est désolé de
vous le dire vous pouvez déjà lu je le
reverrai à léon vacances avec tes encore
raté et oui je vous encourage très
devenir hétéro c'est foutu non laurent
c'est pas possible
c'est quand ça c'est pas beau
malgré une petite difficulté à repérer
les isoloirs
valérie pécresse à elle validé son vote
du côté de vélizy dans les yvelines si
on se base sur les sur les dom tom c'est
un vote ultra massif pour marine le pen
mais c'est sans doute pas le cas alors
non on peut pas dire ça on parle mais
premier tour vous allez bientôt de
retour dans les dents les résultats
qu'on a eus de surveillance pour
l'instant départ du tour des estimations
c'était votre joker mauriste voilà voilà
des choses dont on a entendu parler mais
qui ne sont pas certaine à présager du
vote des électeurs des dom-tom avant 21
heures
[Musique]
nous le découvrons ensemble le président
de la république pour les cinq
prochaines années est emmanuel macron
avec 57 3% des suffrages selon les
estimations harris interactive toluna
est tout de suite vous découvrez
l'ambiance au champ de mars où les
drapeaux bleu blanc rouge fleurissent et
sont agités show où ils ont
enflammé enflammé oui et d'abord il faut
prendre acte du résultat il est là
mais surtout il ne faudrait pas que le
président de la république ce ministre
et son gouvernement prenne le melon
parce que c'est pas la saison d'abord
vous savez monsieur minery aventure ça
commence avant seulement juillet non
mais je dis ça parce que 58% de français
n'ont pas voté pour le projet porté par
la république en marché et le président
de la république il s'appelle idée
fumiyo chiba devenu une véritable star
au japon en prenant une thérapie par les
larmes selon lui pleurer permet de
libérer plusieurs hormones comme
l'ocytocine la vasopressine ou le
cortisol qui agissent comme de
véritables anesthésiant naturel la
posologie pleurait une fois par semaine
pour réduire son niveau de stress même à
l'époque du premier confinement est la
crise du papier toilette on ne faisait
pas parler de ces français qui a acheté
du papier toilette c'est d'une tristesse
sans bornes en fait ses adieux en fait
c'est une ânerie semaine même rythme et
c'est la peur donc jeu complet antoniets
n'est pas d'accord le public non plus
n'est pas d'accord
moi j'ai connu la crise du papier
toilette et quand je suis arrivé devant
un rayon de papier toilette vide et que
j'ai dû me servir de mes mains pendant
quelques jours je me suis dit que ça
m'arriverait plus jamais
emmanuel macron réélu
pour un nouveau mandat de cinq ans
entourée de ses enfants comme une façon
de symboliser ce qu'il veut comme l'un
de ses dossiers prioritaires de son
second quinquennat la jeunesse il nous
l'a dit à plusieurs reprises au cours de
cette campagne s'avère on a beaucoup
parlé de la réforme des retraites mais
nous a dit à plusieurs reprises que ces
deux priorités pour son nouveau mandat
ce serait l'éducation la jeunesse et la
santé ces ateliers réunissent des
milliers d'adeptes dans son pays et des
sessions collectives de pleurs sont
organisées comme ici où des employés se
réunissent chaque jeudi pour chialer un
bon coup de vent un film émouvant au
début je ne pensais pas que j'arriverais
à pleurer face à d'autres gens mais
j'avais beaucoup d'émotion a cumulé en
moi qui avais besoin de sortir c'est
comme un nettoyage une détox je me sens
totalement vidé le tout sous les yeux
d'un sommelier des larmes qui est là
pour essuyer vos pleurs
[Musique]